[Music]
just hours after delhi's local
government announced a week-long curfew
thousands of migrant workers rushed to
bus and train stations
they squeezed their way onto buses
climbing on top of each other
and onto the roofs the closing down of
all but essential services has seen
many workers lose their livelihoods
delhi's chief minister said that nobody
needs to leave delhi
ask him where would daily wage earners
like us go
what will we do they earn and eat the
same day
if they don't earn in the day they can't
have a meal at night
where will we go if not home these are
the same questions which were asked
during the nationwide lockdown a year
ago
it led to a hundred million migrant
workers returning to their home states
after losing their jobs
millions had to walk home hundreds died
on the journey
there's some lives that need to be
protected but the large number of lives
that are
completely indispensable uh for the
government
for the middle class and for the rich
and i think this holds up a very
very alarming mirror to what we have
become as a people
hashmander is petitioning the supreme
court to force the government to provide
basic services to daily wage earners
dali's high court has asked the local
government to divert hundreds of
millions of dollars of public money
to ensure workers who've lost their jobs
don't go hungry
it said both the central and state
governments failed in their
responsibility
to protect daily wage earners last year
and
asked why they haven't made plans to do
better
the high court also said the capital's
healthcare capacity is at the stage of
imminent collapse
health experts say it's likely the
double mutant variation of the virus
which has been found in india that's
causing infections to rise
much more rapidly than last year we've
seen a systematic increase in cases
across india more or less taking off at
the same time suggesting that
what might be happening is that
something that is more transmissible
between people
is very rapidly moving through the
population of people who are yet to
contract the infection
and therefore spreading faster the world
health organization and governments
around the world are monitoring what's
happening in india
as concerns grow about the spread of
this variant
elizabeth piranha al jazeera new delhi